yeah you know what welcome to this video
playing Jeff PK 11 playing the hyper
accelerated dragon here do we get as a
Knight c3 set up not the Milwaukee mind
yeah here there are many lines mostly
there is this one with the coming with a
later be fine I have to admit that i'm
not an expert at all just trying trying
it out yeah it seems to be theoretically
when established line white player is
playing quite quickly aha
so he tries to chick meet me quite
obviously not being very subtle about
things okay so and what am I doing here
cooksey 81 yes maybe threatens probably
like a 40 and Bishop f5
no problem I don't have much experience
with those positions and first glance
you I mean I would think that the bishop
only three looks a bit strange looking
at its own porn it doesn't doesn't
really do much but my king site is
pretty barren so might still be very
dangerous there was reform
what is my idea actually maybe a for
Bishop a to Bishop of five c3b for
something like that why does taking a
long time he always has something like
cuenta de fossa he is going for direct
kill okay don't you push him back and I
will take it yeah this ice thought would
work because of Bishop f5 maybe I'm too
slow with with this but
[Music]
push it a 5 c 3 before ft86 is ok I
think this is I can play I people
submission oh my god now that that's not
that was not on my radar at all
yeah you know I mean I don't don't see
how I'm checkmated at the moment now we
play c3 anyway okay well
[Music]
pour em
I've never played the proper dragon I
can one once once in my whole life and
that game over very lucky not to against
not getting chicken it ain't no why I
don't play the dragon [ __ ] me what a
position so what sorts the threat taking
on g6 probably
I hate this position
[Music]
this will Queen g2 takes 26 creamy to
maybe it's a funny trick is it is good i
was thinking this is good
I'm threatening on h1 now and he doesn't
have a check Queenie several maybe but
then I can take on g6 at least on g6
with check yes let's do it threatening
Queen g1 all of a sudden
the aquine e2m can play Queen enjoy
learning
okay okay
amazing okay
check check check check check check
check check okay moving on time of
course yet check check check may not
look like this ah so once in a while is
some justice in this game but just once
in a while he started to play on time
far too far too early yeah all this way
call super complicated position p yeah i
know this is this of some kind of
theoretical line but i don't know any
details yeah so this this I have no idea
this is correct looks it too oh yeah
this is not difficult why don't I see
those motorcyle sometimes don't know
yeah just not difficult you know this is
this is yes good one and yes this is
fantastic because I continue to attack
while let wipes attack without Queens is
pretty much non-existent him so this is
this ended the game basically I can
still take one little while I'm bad
against it here and we can take I was
just hoping to survive this the engine
is just giving this and I'm
lost him I saw this it wasn't wasn't
that clear to me yet even that is clear
okay again you can just do this okay so
we both dodged some bullets here Quincy
to me okay yeah I should win but this is
just the world holding tweenage form so
when schedule h eight is winning okay
okay okay Queenie for now I'll oh I
overlooked so many simple wins that it's
really crazy and he took f1 for whatever
reason queen bee ADA's winning yeah yeah
this is should have put in a drawer
because both players show total
incompetents Wow okay thanks for
watching I forgot to switch their own
yeah well as I told you the key things
thanks for watching